يوم الثلاثاء الموعد المرتقب لمصول الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب امام المحكمه في
نيويورك وحملته كشفت عن بعض التفاصيل وفقا
لحمله دونالد ترامب للانتخابات الرئاسيه
المقبله يخطط ترامب للسفر الى نيويورك بعد
توجيه اتهام له من قبل هيئه محلفين كبرى
في منهاته حسبما كشفت الحمله سيقضي الرئيس
الامريكي السابق عطله نهايه الاسبوع في
مره لاغو ومن المتوقع ان يحافظ على جدوله
المعتاد في منتصف نهار الاثنين من المقرر
ان يسافر ترامب الى نيويورك عبر طائرته
الخاصه على ان يقضي الليله في شقته في برج
ترامب في من هاتن قبل التوجه للمحكمه بحسب
تقرير لشبكه سي ان ان فقد يتم تاجيل
القضايا الاخرى المقرر عقدها امام محكمه
من هاته الجنائيه يوم الثلاثاء ومن
المتوقع ان يتم توجيه الاتهام الى ترامب
في الساعه الثانيه والربع بعد الظهر
بتوقيت شرق الولايات المتحده او السادسه
والربع مساء بتوقيت جرينتش محامي ترامب
انه لن يتم وضعه الاصفاد في يدي الرئيس
الامريكي سابق وعلى ان يطلق سراحه بعد
توجيه الاتهام اليه وان يعود الى فلوريدا
في الاثناء لا تزال تفاصيل تهم التي
واجهتها هيئه المحلفين الكبرى لترامب سريه
الا ان مصادر قالت لسي ان ان ترامب يواجه
اكثر من 30 تهمه تتعلق بالاحتيال التجاري
اما في جانب تحضيرات الحمله الانتخابيه
فمن المتوقع ان يعود ترامب لاستئنافها يوم
الاربعاء